ich glaube wir haben es in Berlin damit
zu tun dass das grüne verkehrspolitische
Programm insgesamt nur heißen kann Wege
zum Stillstand da geht's ja nicht nur um
die Frage die Innenstadt von Autos
freizuhalten wir haben eine
verkehrssenatorin von den Grünen in
Berlin die um jeden Preis 500 Meter
Straße hier in der Nähe in der
Friedrichstraße sperren will und sich
nicht darum kümmert das U-Bahnen nicht
mehr fahren am gleichen Tag sind zwei
ganz wichtige U-Bahn Strecken hier in
Berlin gesperrt worden an dem sie die
Friedrichstraße gesperrt hat wir haben
ein Problem mit ganz anderen
Verkehrsträgern die S-Bahn der Zentrale
Tunnel ist gesperrt die verkehrsinatorin
kümmert sich nicht darum dass dieses
Baustellen Chaos Gehalt wird und selbst
im Luftverkehr sieht so aus dass bald
jeder Provinzflughafen mehr
internationale Verbindungen hat als
Berlin also insofern kann ich nur sagen
dieses stillstandsprogramm das muss
Enden das ist das Grundproblem grüner
Politik und zum Thema Elektromobilität
keiner von uns hat was dagegen
elektrisch zu fahren aber wenn die
Infrastruktur nicht da ist dann ist die
Kernaussage doch man will das Auto gar
nicht in der Stadt und da muss man sich
dann einfach Berlin umschauen viele
viele Menschen sind überhaupt darauf
angewiesen um sich bewegen zu können da
gibt's keine U-Bahn da gibt's keine
S-Bahn und davor die Augen zu
verschließen das ist grüne
Realitätsverweigerung freie Fahrt für
freie Bürger ist sozusagen das Motto so
ein bisschen Peter glaubst du das wird
viele für ein Kreuzchen bewegen ist das
auch ein Thema das bei dir so ein
bisschen ins Herz trifft ich wohne in
Kreuzberg bei mir bei mir sind also
jetzt mal einfach nur aus dem Hauptstadt
leben das ist auch etwas was glaube ich
noch woanders droht bei mir um um die
Ecke da wo der nutzius sitzt da sind
zwei Friedhöfe der nunius sitzt da neben
der Kirche und dann ist da noch eine
Laubenkolonie unter parken immer die
Handwerker Autos der packten die Leute
mit den Marktständen die konnten da ganz
in Ruhe kurz vor der Polizei alles
abstellen das Ding ist so eine
anwohnerparkzone gemacht worden die
Männer liegenden tote das ist ein
anwohnerparkzone jetzt kann er niemand
mehr was abstellen was ist die Folge
dass die Autos jetzt woanders stehen
nämlich in den Wohngebieten und die
Parkplätze wegnehmen weil die Leute vor
der Haustür dann werden Parkplätze von
fast über Nacht handstreichartig den
ganzen Straßen abgeschafft dann gibt's
eine Tempo 30 Zone in einer Tempo 30
Zone darfst du keine extra Fahrradstraße
anlegen nur Tempo 30 aufgehoben der
Fahrradweg wird
durchgebaute Politik die wild mit
Verboten Arbeiten die wir die Menschen
in ein Korsett reinzwingen so kann Foto
darf Politik nicht funktionieren zwar
nirgends auf der auf der Welt man hat
den Bürgern ein Angebot zu machen und
mir die freie Wahl zu lassen nicht freie
Fahrt für freie Bürger sondern freie
Wahl für freie Bürgerschaft Angebote die
attraktiv sind die es mir ermöglichen
auf das Auto an bestimmten Sachen zu
verzichten das ist Politik so muss
Politik funktionieren die ist nämlich
für die Bürger und nicht gegen die
Bürger da und Politiker der muss Gesetze
Ausführen der hat eine Verwaltung sich
jetzt zuzustellen und die Sicherheit und
die Ordnung sicher zu stellen aber er
ist nicht der Volkszähler wir sind nicht
in der DDR
nicht unbedingt immer eins ja wir sind
Exportnation Autos ist das ganz große
Thema in Deutschland glauben Sie sie
können es irgendwie beziffern sollten
wir jetzt mal so weit denken dass wir
sagen in Städte frei von Autos immer
noch Elektromobilität was glauben Sie
wie viele Arbeitsplätze könnten uns da
verlangen naja die Frage
Elektromobilität lassen wir mal außen
vor dass ein großes Streit Thema ich bin
da sehr skeptisch im übrigen aber
ein anderer Punkt ist ja auch sehr
interessant und zwar man stellt sich vor
Sie haben das erwähnt wir wollen keine
Autos mehr aber die Idee dahinter ist
doch ich mache das andere nicht
attraktiv sondern das andere mache ich
schlechter und nur so funktioniert ich
habe vor ich weiß nicht 2 Jahren mal
gelesen von einem Stadtrat in Berlin in
Friedrichshain Kreuzberg ja der hat der
hat dann der hat dann geschrieben er
musste leider jetzt mal das Auto nehmen
um zum Rathaus zu kommen und er hat
gemerkt er kommt zu viel besser dahin
und die Schlussfolgerung dir gezogen hat
die war klasse er sagte nämlich
ja Autofahren muss attraktiver werden
nicht dass nicht die öffentlichen
Nahverkehrsmittel müssen besser werden
und das ist aber letztendlich die
Quintessenz das Sozialismus wir können
es nicht für alle gut machen wir machen
für alle schlecht ja